- Deon, I've got a game for you.
Are you ready?
- Yes.
- OK, we're gonna play a game
I call "Zoom Around The Room".
(game music)
It's super easy.
Parents, you can play it
at home with your kids.
I know we're running out of
things to do at this point,
so I feel you, I'm waving
the white flag too.
But here's how it's done.
We'll be given a random word or phrase
from my executive producer,
which I do not know.
'Cause I don't cheat, Jane Lynch.
(laughing)
Then we run and find an
object to match that,
like whatever they've said.
So the first person back to
their camera with an item
gets the point.
Are you ready?
- OK
- First clue is,
fuzzy!
OK, fuzzy!
(game timer)
Is it fuzzy or furry, fuzzy or fury?
(Kelly laughing)
(Deon laughing)
Can I tell you the best part of this?
First of all, I don't know
if mine is fuzzy or furry.
But secondly,
I have been sitting on the
identical pillow behind me.
(Deon laughing)
And I just figured that out walking back.
I'm an idiot.
(Deon cracking up)
- You could have just went like this.
You could have just...
- I didn't even realize
I was sitting on...
I just ran out there
to look for something.
I really think, mines furry, not fuzzy.
I don't know.
What's yours, is that your blankie?
(Deon laughing)
- Don't tell nobody, this is my blanket.
- I love it.
Is that Linus from Charlie Brown?
(laughing)
I love that.
OK, you get that point, whatever.
I can not believe the matching one--
- It was right there. (laughing)
- How stupid am I?
OK, so let's go to the next word.
What's the next one?
Golden!
(game timer)
Oh, yeah!
Yes!
(laughing)
OK, I win because I got here first,
but you win because yours is way cooler.
(laughing)
I like a candle-lit, like--
- You got a candle-lit. (laughing)
I got, uh, I got a gold chain. (laughing)
- Yeah, that's a lot
more expensive than this,
I can promise you.
(Deon laughing and clapping)
This you can get at Hobby Lobby.
(Deon laughing)
So I win the point, but you win in life.
(laughing)
All right, here we go,
let's do another one.
Give it to us.
Sexy.
Wait, what?
Heyyy!
I'm just stayin' here!
The clue is sexy!
- [Deon] I can't stay
there, Kelly, I can't do it!
- What?
Your sexy Deon!
Come back!
Wait, should I really go find something?
- OK.
- [Kelly] Wait, hold up (voice fading)
- My scarf is sexy.
You could've stayed there, Kelly!
- No, I have an idea!
That was cheating.
You win.
Wait, what?
OK scarf.
(Deon laughing)
OK scarf, what's happenin'?
- I just grabbed a scarf,
I thought this was sexy.
- I like it, it's red,
the color of seduction.
I like it.
(Deon laughing)
Here's mine, I'm gonna explain mine.
This is, I recently
purchased a Peloton Bike.
She's sexyer body.
But then the seat hurts my behind.
(Deon chuckling)
I don't know how anybody
ride with that damn seat.
It hurts my butt so bad.
So I bought a bigger seat for my behind.
- Nice.
- This is gonna get me to
sexy, ya' all, this is it.
- That's the sexy seat.
You should have just stayed there.
You won already, you was there.
- I thought it was clever,
but it was cheating.
- Yeah, it was great!
- OK, one more, una mas.
OK, una mas, let's do it again, one more.
(game music)
What, scary?
- What's this?
What is it?
[Kelly] Scary!
- Scary!
- [Deon] You got somethin'?
- [Kelly] Hold on, yeah.
(game timer)
I got it, OK, OK.
This is scary.
What are you holding!
(laughing)
What are you holding?
And I'm so excited.
(laughing)
What's happening?
- It's a mask of me.
- My god, I love you for owning this mask.
(both laughing)
I have nothing scary in my house,
'cause I don't like scary things.
But I will tell you,
me playing this instrument
is just about as scary as
me playing piano, so yeah.
(Deon laughing)
I thought that's scary.
Like, I played on tour once,
and I'm like, "Why am I doing this?"
'Cause this is haunting to
even have this in the mix.
'Cause I'm like totally,
"I could be Johnny Cash.",
and then it turns out,
"Nope, just a singer."
- It's weird.
- You know, it was a
tie, but I'm gonna say,
point-wise it was a tie,
but I'm gonna say you won,
'cause like the guitar
thing didn't even count,
I have nothing scary to show.
So you win!
Deon wins!
(winning game music)
- Yeah! Thank you!